en apparence il ne reste que quelques
petits détails à régler mais pour
l'instant seuls les journalistes et
quelques invités peuvent monter à bord
des trains automatisés alors nous voici
enfin dans la voiture du REM dans une
des voitures d'urannes la promesse sera
tenue à sur les responsables le tronçon
entre Brossard et le centre-ville et ses
18 minutes de temps de parcours sera
inauguré ce printemps mais pas avant fin
mai le temps de s'arrimer avec les
autres réseaux pour patienter nous avons
accès au centre de contrôle au total 250
personnes assureront la circulation et
la maintenance des trains sur ce tronçon
de 16 km et 5 stations on les réveille
d'ici on leur affecte une mission on
leur dit toi le train numéro 1 voilà ce
que tu vas faire aujourd'hui tu vas
faire 50 aller-retours entre Brossard et
la gare centrale un train sans
conducteur ça veut dire des wagons dans
lesquels les voyageurs ont accès aux
panorama à l'avant comme à l'arrière du
train ça veut dire aussi des fréquences
plus élevées 3 minutes 30 pour ce
premier segment en heure de pointe 7
minutes 30 en dehors des heures de
pointe la composante humaine est
toujours là composante la plus
la moins sûre parce que l'humain il est
FIA il est faillible le système il l'est
pas et il n'a pas intérêt à l'être selon
cette expert sinon un léger qui laissait
bon l'abandonner ils vont jamais revenir
et deuxièmement l'opinion populaire va
être contre le système et les phases 2
Phase 3 phase 4 qui sont nécessaires
pour les prochaines décennies ne verront
pas le jour l'ouverture des tronçons
nord et ouest et toujours prévu d'ici la
fin de l'année prochaine 2027 pour
l'aéroport ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Brossard